bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono vaghi j
oggi siamo tornati sul file night at
freddy's due praticamente ragazzi
dall'ultima volta che ci ho giocato è
tutto un casino in casinò di consigli su
come andare avanti perché è un po
difficile ma aveva questo l'avevo notato
comunque detto che prima in testa questa
maschera qui che si mette addosso si
mette quando devo stare attento che non
mi arrivino i tizi quelli belli davanti
se non sapete di che ti sto parlando
aspettate cinque minuti e poi [ __ ]
chiave per chi ha detto ragazzi che
dovevo tenere la musica la devo tenere
sempre che sono fisco vabbè che non c'è
più nessuno fantastico io gli avevo
chiamati malissimo rotta si chiamano
chico e vanni quei due con giornale che
ha seriamente cazzo cinque minuti
ciao bello non mi ricordo torna da
bonnie boni schema boni un giorno buon
george colta m'incazzo musica la musica
ad ottenere si pronti devi muovere
perché porta tra ragazzi devo tenere la
musica non c'è più cosa non illumina non
mi funziona b la torcia fa bene a
bellone zero nei condotti non c'è un
caso la scatenati ma devo tenermi fatti
a vedere dove sono ok ma non c'è un
cazzo dove soffia finire perché se non
li vedo potrebbe essere un problema di
quando no di qua salve
il fratello ascoltami il cazzo ti ha
messo là dentro fermi che devo
controllare lo spazio che bello era che
chi è che ti ha messo sentito un rumore
brutto sentito la scaletta che cazzo
succedere che cos'è e cosa solo 0 ma
ciao senti invitiamo qualcuno non lo so
porca [ __ ] st musica cala [ __ ] porta
dato una botta allucinante col ginocchio
sullo spigolo c'è giusto per farvi
capire il mio grado di incazzatura ok
ragazzi non ufficialmente capito un
cazzo perché sono morto guarda bello
veramente vengono ma sto gioco mi
ispirano veramente 70 di quella roba da
giocare che folli che cazzo presto
questo ma che poi ragazzi non ho capito
lì ogni tanto spunta una volpe ma ma chi
cazzo è stavolta che qua non c'è nessuno
ci sono sì 3 poi la volpe da dove spunta
da notizia lo so ho capito tutto tranne
la voi la volpe proprio non riesco a
capire da dove su che a qualcuno allora
l'avevo visto bello di questa buona
figlia e di giorno e una pizzeria mi
pare novo anni non romperle padre ti
prego ti press in quel che è che bello
ragazzi sentono rumori brutti
buongiorno ascolti dei mimi mi fa capire
come ci è arrivato lì perché non è mafia
si fa rispondi komaki che porta via le
cose e poi c'è un bambino che parla e
bellissimo stop giuro veramente
un'ispirazione buongiorno sa per caso
ecco lui lui mi attacca però io non lo
so ok ok ok se devi mettere little di
madonna e botta di culo ragazza sono
vivo no perché c'è la volpe di merda
perfetto perfetto no no no no no no no
ma mi attacca è un pupazzo non può
attaccarmi questo credo e non sa non ne
sono completamente sicuro per forza che
cazzo ci fai la 4 lì non ce la fa
mancava la tua madre che più brutta di
te te lo giuro comunque ragazzi è una
cosa da puntualizzare ma con tecnica st
mascara ma voglio non solo che si prende
ma la voglio bene fate di qua ok non ce
ne sono ancora non si sono mossi un
miracolo è già luna e sai sono ancora lì
che culo cioè non dovevo dire un
consapevole ma tanto venute che io parlo
freddi boni chi cazzo certo non sono
spariti tutti ho detto sta frase dopo
due secondi sono spariti tutti
bellissimi
non lo voglio il tuo cazzo di dolce vai
via
la musica c'è culo l'ho presa l'ho presa
all'ultimo già fatta sì no no eh vabbè
però dai che palle vai muoviti a sparire
lo sparisce regalo rimanere così per
molto
cosa faccio cosa faccio
si vabbè dai metteva bene mettiamo anche
gesù si è fatto commessa come sa c'è
nessuno ancora lì che palle che cosa ci
stai facendo tu qua ragazzi e ragazzi no
no
no no no no non ce la posso fare non ce
la posso fare non ce la posso fare
sì ho fatto forse non già fatta manco pe
ri cazzo perché c'è gente brutta ma
proprio brutta davanti in faccia potuto
gioco di murray ora che annuncia ho
rotto le cuffie una volta mi sto tenendo
perché non è un ripido anche sbavato
perfetto ragazzi sono tornati in forze
perché ho ascoltato roma buona non
provare a giocarci costa musica rito
dove è bellissima mi sembra la musica
giusta per un gioco giusto quindi usiamo
questo è bellissimo perché ti porta
il pericolo sta funzionando ragazzi sta
roba qualcuno diventa più difficile ogni
volta ogni notte di più quindi c'è
questa era e la notte più una delle più
facili pensate voi no no no che sai che
palle che sei giorni che palle vai
ascoltati st musica ti puoi togliere da
quel cazzo di soffitto per favore no no
non fredda vi prego no non ho mica tutto
non ha funzionato la musica non ha
funzionato una sega una sega ok allora
carica mi devo devo far niente più caio
ogni volta guarda lì non c'è più nessuno
e orribile dov'è che siete riprendere io
non so neanche come finiscono stili e
quello il brutto non posso neanche dalla
la luisona la chitarra nella tre giorni
buongiorno androni state sai quindi vuol
dire che mi deve spuntare di qua per
forza perché no di qua non lo so non è
veramente possibile un giorno ascoltami
lo so che sei bella e sexy però fa
infatti un paio di cazzi tuoi non lo so
però è di che non sono andato a [ __ ]
perfetto box i pozzi no no è andata lì
per chi dovrà cambiare posto nella
comoda la cosa che non riesco a capire
legate veramente incasinata
[ __ ] c'è questi impellenti bisogno
di rompere i condotti me lo spieghi
siamo alle 2 di notte ce la farò non ce
la faccio forse devi smettere di non
pericoli per favore non si vede che che
vendono a chi pupazzi di ste cagate vai
vai vai vai vai mai dai ragazzi già sto
facendo con corna al massimo bene è
andata via perfetto ma anche no no no ti
supplico per far sì che ti prego in
cinese
allora a questo punto ragazzi non so che
cosa fare rimango così no non lo so
rimango così fa che tanto mi ammazzano
quindi [ __ ]
ok ok niente non funziona la torcia è
andato a [ __ ] contrario cioè a
[ __ ]
io mi rassegno perché anzi di tirassegno
non mira sente la battuta rattrista lo
so che era triste perdere in tutti i
modi possibile allucinate voce sto cazzo
di ventilatore ci sono meno 3 gradi lo
so perché sento posso sentire il freddo
ok non ce ne sono due di nonno preciso
sono agitato alle 2 di notte mancano
ancora 3 4 o resa impossibile ragazze
seriamente la cosa strana disco gioco
che se metto la musica se non detto la
musica aperto segmento musica aperto e
allora che cazzo per cos'è che è
ciao no no no
un sentimento allora io ammetto che un
piano via gori fuori dopo hai presente
il bagno ecco vicino a bagno ce la porta
per andare fuori a [ __ ] perfetto non
hai capito un cazzo
all amasco la maschera o la [ __ ]
maschera no no no calma calma guarda che
li vedi quanto sono bello calma ragazzi
fa forse forse ce la facciamo è qua sono
non so anch'io sono bello no non mi a
cag atto distrib
non ho capito perché sia affezionato
costanza giorno mi mediche sola maschera
mi sta scadendo la musica [ __ ]
come faccio come faccio che sulla musica
a te ne vai sì boni non ad ogni per
favore anche tu non è la musica cazzo
sono ancora le 4 di notte le cinque no
basta freddi per favore per favore via
dalle poi via è andato non è vero non
sono anche se vanno via e quello con le
mani vista questa è l'ora stiamo qua
giochiamo insieme ok ti va di giocare
chi va di toccare testa di sea port
calmi calmi
piano piano andato via andato via
che è rompipalle rega non è possibile
voglio arrivare ste 6 per favore falla
arrivare non ne possiamo alla fine siamo
alla fiction
bastava [ __ ] basta migliorano
l'ottico basta sono cinque ore che gioco
sono cinque ore che non vinco mi sono
rotto i co
mi sono rotto i cogl che cazzo guardi
cosa ti guarda ti stacco gli occhi
[Musica]
sì sì sì sì sì faccio io
oh mio dio ragazzi basta è stato
approccio verso delle ore della mia vita
perché cosa canzone sta roba collo di
casa eccentrica siamo ma sono dentro
freddi che piaccio succedere che carica
che bastasse è una festa di compleanno
io sono stato un inferno che lasciamo
perdere ragazzi che già è stato che cosa
cazzo succede a night 3 perfetto col
cazzo
grazie di tutto siete bellissimi ma
proprio basta grazie era chiamato
ragazzi è stato assurdo basta veramente
basta non il suo sembra sono
probabilmente sono io e prova a [ __ ]
non è possibile comunque ragazze o
capitolo seguite i vostri consigli però
non è né solito un cazzo uguale però vi
ringrazio quindi ragazzi servito era
piaciuto ma sai cosa documento mi piace
anche a parte anni facebook che come noi
di video fate una descrizione prestiti
siete lì ci vediamo non fossero quelle
ragazze